hey it's time for another movie review
this time around we're doing something a
little bit different not an exactly a
movie no it's a web series it's a web
series and it's actually a fan series a
Star Trek fan series yeah you wouldn't
know by looking at it though this thing
is awesome yeah we wouldn't like I guess
we wouldn't really necessarily do this
kind of thing but this one is really in
a class by itself
yeah it really stands out this is real
Star Trek if you yeah if you grew up on
the original series you've got to see
this all right if you haven't seen it
yet it's really and like I said I'm not
a huge Star Trek geek or anything like
that it's like I'm a fan of the original
series not like a super fan you know
I've seen all the episodes a couple of
times a couple of the other ones I could
take or leave you know we saw her a
prize we saw you know I've seen some of
the other ones that I'm not as thrilled
about those but I really really like the
original series and this is almost
exactly like it yeah it's it's real Star
Trek the writing is awesome the acting
is really good you got vic Mignogna
vic Mignogna basically he's Kirk oh yeah
there are only two Kirk's all right you
got the shat and then you got them me
really invented Kirk oh you know a lot
of the mannerisms and a lot of the way
Kirk does Kirk Lee things in the
original seriously yeah is more kind of
like that that's that's the shat being
himself all right so he kind of you know
the shat brings a lot to the table in
terms of you know Captain Kirk action
and turn up in terms of the Captain Kirk
game but Manyana comes in Vic comes in
and he gives you that exact same
character but without sit without doing
a Shatner impersonation yeah this is you
know I mean like you sometimes forget
that you're not dealing with William
Shatner yes I mean especially certain
facial expressions like when he turns
his head a certain way or something like
that he really really looks like Shatner
day on the original series and he has
said this numerous times in interviews
because he is a huge fan of the original
Star Trek and Captain Kirk was his
favorite character
as a child so he has specifically said I
wanted to do this to honor the series
he's like I didn't want to parody Kirk
right I didn't want to make it seem like
I was spoofing him or making fun of him
and that really comes across in the show
it's almost more like it's not an
impression of William Shatner it's
almost more like he's channeling that
character yes like he's channeling Kirk
yeah the guys that make this web series
they're very well connected yeah pretty
much the people that wrote these
episodes also wrote Star Trek episodes
people who've starred on Star Trek shows
up at show up as guest stars on this so
this isn't really it's fan-made it's not
an amateur production no this is a
professional production yes and pretty
much I mean all of the principal actors
vick todd haberkorn who plays spock yeah
any 50 plays are really cool yeah they
are all primarily voice actors yeah um a
lot of them have been in other Star Trek
properties yeah some of them are on
discovery some of them have been on the
online series you know some of them have
done Barry's yes some of them were from
enterprise you also have a lot of guest
stars like you're the guy who played q
guest stars on one episode yeah you have
Lou Ferrigno clays and Orion slave
master on one he was so good yeah yeah
that's really good Aaron gray yeah she's
not she's so it's it's an all-star cast
and the special effects are really good
they're it's true to the original series
but day because of modern technology
they're able to improve a lot of special
effects but they still keep that same
tone it's very fallout for you know in
terms of weapon jury in the way phaser
fire looks and it looks really cool yeah
and one of the first things that I I
mean what ended up happening give a
little bit of the history of if you
don't know about it vic Mignogna have
like I said was a huge Star Trek fan and
what he wanted to do was start a web
series that essentially finished the
original crews five-year mission
right so it's like a this is like a
bonus season yeah Star Trek because when
the original series ended they never
wrapped things up and yes ended yeah and
this one is a really good way of ending
the the original series and kind of
slowly blending it into the very first
Star Trek the motion picture yeah it
ties into that gap in between the last
episode of the original series and the
motion picture and kind of explains why
certain things yeah turned out the way
they did yeah like why did Spock go back
to Vulcan right you know you know
because in the motion picture he had to
basically come back to star right and
why it's why did Kirk take a desk job
yeah you know and then why are certain
things in the next generation a certain
way well all that stuff is answered in
the Syria and also what's really cool is
that I think it was episode three or
four which is the one about the mirror
episode was at 3 or 4 do you know I
think it was I think it was 3 okay
in episode 3 they actually revisit the
mirror universe to find out what mirror
universe Spock did after he met Kirk
after kur after the real Kirk left and
what
yeah they don't you know fans will know
that you know that in the mirror
universe Spock kind of had this sinister
looking mustache yeah demonic looking
beard well you find out what happened
when Kirk goes back to our universe and
leave Spock on his own it's a really
cool episode yes they revisit a lot of
stuff and they kind of did that with a
lot of the episode it's not so much that
they I mean a lot of them are original
stories obviously yeah but they will
take some of their favorite episodes
like the mirror mirror episode like the
one about Apollo right yeah from the
original series and then kind of like
work off of that you're there saying
like you know what happened afterwards
you know what happened to that planet
after we left that guy what happened to
this yeah what happened to Apollo
yeah yeah that's the brief which was
actually the first day which is called
pilgrim of eternity I think and they got
the same guy that played upon the
original series like I said these dudes
are connected this is yeah
like somebody hate asking their little
sister to be in the production or
whatever yeah these most of the people
on here have been in some other Star
Trek program and some people well
they're the descendant of somebody they
like like Scotty in this series is the
son of Doonan of yeah of the original
the original guy that play the yeah some
of the like the girl I think the girl
from the mirror universe that Kirk you
know they were the captain's woman yeah
I think that was the descendant the
daughter I think that was the daughter
it was one of the two either her one of
the war it was the Romulan captain
female oh yeah it hurt yeah Hey look
they're just spitting image I think it
is the Raman laser oh yeah that was like
in the last to the big finale episode
finale the woman that plays the Romulan
captain Ross the daughter of the woman
that played her original series and you
know in the original series you know
Spock only had well he had a lot of
almost girlfriends but one of the many
nobles girlfriend was the the Romulan
female captain that he seduced in order
to get that secret mission done and
there in the neutral zone yeah so they
bring her back there's a lot of really
cool stuff in the series but I mean the
cool thing and when I first started
watching this because the first episode
pilgrim of eternity vic Mignogna has
said I just made it he it was
self-funded yeah he just wanted to make
it he's like I wanted to fill in the
gaps like continue the mission yeah and
I didn't know if anyone would want to
watch it I didn't know so I just wanted
to make it cuz I wanted to yeah it was a
hit with everybody who saw it yeah the
thing with this is not a lot of people
saw it yeah it was kind of the same with
the original series it really can become
super famous until years after when it
went into syndication well that's what's
happening with Star Trek continues right
now a lot of people are finding it for
the very first time I showed it to my
friend Mike a guy who I grew up with and
he just loves it you know you just kind
of came across it because it's been at
the first episode came out in 2013
yes they take a long time to make yeah
you know after the first episode was
very successful he actually started a
couple of kick starters yeah and got a
lot of money well I got way more more
money
well I think he did to kick sirs which
he called Kirk starters which oh yeah
that's adorable
and also he did an IndieGoGo campaign
and he ended up getting a lot more than
he asked for so they did end up making
11 episodes now I think originally they
were going to make 13 right but yet they
not make 13 because they ran out of
money or be no CBS told us there was
another fan film that was getting ready
to happen called Axanar and they were
taking money and not suspending it in
certain ways that made it a for-profit
or possibly a for-profit venture and CBS
said okay that's it no more stuff and
then they said Vic you can finish up
your series you know we don't we're not
gonna worry about that but no more fan
stuff now hopefully they're gonna relax
on the fan stuff
yeah actually maybe when Axanar blows
over when it's done you know we don't
know but I'll tell you one thing I this
would have made a fantastic Netflix
series oh yeah here's nothing CBS owns
the property to this yeah they have a
new Star Trek's called Star Trek
Discovery I think it was somebody say it
was like eight million dollars an
episode which is a ridiculous amount of
money to put in and maybe it was five
million in Episode four five to eight
million dollars you could probably make
three seasons of this and on see is a
streaming service they give that and
they probably get a [ __ ] ton of people
who want old classic Trek this is the
Star Trek that you grew up with yeah you
thick a Star Trek this is it not so much
the new stuff although they could play
out I hope the new one
you know succeeds yeah just I mean well
the thing is and we were watching a
couple interviews with Vick last night
in preparation for doing this review and
he's kind of like well Star Trek
discoveries like it you know if you like
it that's great he's like but I don't
really think it's for me it's like it's
not he's like they have to appeal to a
wider audience I mean it's not a big
network and they spent they spent a lot
of money on it so it's just kind of more
like you know more like the JJ Abrams
movies where they're not crowd-pleasing
they have to appeal to more people not
just Trekkies so I think it's more kind
of like a generic sci-fi story whereas
the original series and this is why I
like the original series best of all the
Star Trek properties is because it had a
very distinctive style - it had a
distinctive look it had a distinctive
writing style I like a lot of the
writers that wrote for Harlan Ellison
and Richardson and stuff like that I
like that writing style retro format of
the original Trek and this Star Trek
continues that format is kind of filling
a void yeah in the market artistically
it's got a certain feel to it yeah that
almost seems fresh and new now yeah you
see it ironically it's like it's yeah
I'm back into style and really what I'm
hoping is I'm hoping this CBS just
claims the property yeah it clearly is
CBS just cuz ok Star Trek continues is
ours and that means that they could
either cuz I they made they're already
made yeah they could just sell it to
Netflix or they can put it on their own
streaming service and we'd be able to
watch it there then in my mind CBS would
hire victim make more yeah now some
would say well they wrap the series up
how could they make more well the time
period in between a motion picture and
Rafa Khan there's enough to do several
series right there yeah that's true I
didn't think about that yeah and there
were some photographs of Vic and the
crew in those maroon uniforms which is
kind of a hint I was thinking when I
first saw oh maybe they're gonna do
something in between that time period
wouldn't that be awesome
you can do like a series in between them
yeah that's serious right there in began
leading up to Rafa Khan yeah that'd be
awesome because like I said yes to have
it yeah and it wouldn't be a real
expensive venture for the because yeah
prior to this one fan film not Star Trek
continues but at the differ one that
screwed people out of Kickstarter money
or whatever it was they did CBS allowed
you to make fan films as long as you
didn't profit on them right like you
know you could raise money and make them
you couldn't sell them you had to kind
of put them up for free and things like
that which search are continues it has
done they have in YouTube it's up in
high definition
yeah you can watch it you can download
they have covers just right for DVDs you
can burn the DVDs they just put up the
whole series in HD yeah and you can
download download them from their
website in HD for free all the cover art
the you know the blacks are and a bunch
of posters yeah and
after you watch the series you love
these actors as much as the originals I
did yes like it's really funny I was
like it took me an episode or two to
kind of get adjusted yeah annoying me
that these weren't the original actors
doing what warrants but then like by
episode three
you know the mirror episode I'm like no
no I like these guys too yeah I like
these guys
well everyone mana hit their stride kind
of right oh and I forgot to make you
know there's so many people in this like
I said doesn't like the guys that played
war if he does the voice of the computer
is a mirror in a mirror universe it's
Worf that plays the voice of the
computer in the normal universe it's the
voice of Dan Troy yeah that's Aaron they
can do in the ships so like I said it's
like ah it's pretty awesome they've got
like all these like actual Star Trek
people like coming in and like that but
the thing that really struck me because
I think you discovered it and then you
were like you have to see this this is
amazing and when I was watching it I was
like it looks just like the old one
the staging the lighting the way they do
the rocks on them on the alien plant
everything it looks exactly looks
exactly the way the original series
hopes to be seen yeah cuz if there's
something about it it is in that same
spirit but it's like the quality is
better yeah fabulous obviously because
the fabrics are better it's an aged
spend more money on it yeah it in the
phaser fire looks a little a lot better
because it looks you know like it's in
3d like if somebody shoots at you would
actually you know the the phaser beam
you could actually has some depth to it
and there's actually you can see light
moving inside it looks really cool but
it still has that retro spirit to it
like you're seeing something from yeah
60 so that's what I really liked about
it but it looks clean that's what's
weird is its retro and clean at the same
time I mean because for for some things
they did use CGI yeah now he has said
he's like really the only thing they use
CGI for was some of the exterior shots
him of the phaser fire he's like if we
had to have something like a little
gadget that was like flying or something
like that
but they would actually build yeah the
thing yet it don't then just do it on a
green screen they didn't build anything
in entirely in CGI I don't think yeah
the planets are well yet other than the
plan yeah when you see the planets from
orbit I mean they're they're gorgeous
yeah but so oh they still come what's
weird is they're still kind of retro
futuristic looking yeah kind of like
yeah man I mean like like I said they
got the look of it exactly right and up
to the tone of each episode is correct
for the original series well the writing
on is there the writing on it is very
similar to I mean this was kind of
because I grew up reading a lot of
horror and sci-fi by that generation of
writers like I said Harlan Ellison and
people like that so that's kind of
that's a writing style that I always
really liked and it's the same reason
why I liked the original Star Trek the
same reason I like The Twilight Zone
it's it's that kind of writing that kind
of framework and they really did yeah
get that
bang on well I remember when I was a kid
I'd watch the old original series and
you were kind of watching a space
program it had elements of like The
Twilight Zone but it also they were like
morality tales you were learning
something yeah thinking about a certain
issue that they were talking about and
they weren't shoving anything down your
throat they were allowing you to reach
your own conclusions and there's nothing
I love about this this series I would
say that it's political philosophy is
really cool they all talk about an issue
and they'll present multiple sides of
the issue and I think they presented
clearly and they lead they allow you to
reach your own conclusions
what is that are you having it it's very
new on ya throat it doesn't shove things
down your throat the original one was -
yeah they were doing was like that also
I don't like that yeah but that's that's
really what I was talking about with the
how they did the writing and stuff like
that it's it's really really the first
time I watched the series thrips I think
we've watched it about three times
through it this year I was just I
couldn't believe it I was just like
sitting there with my mouth this is just
like yeah it's not trash yeah it's
delightful
it is Star Trek look at that's
and Rob Roddenberry Gene Roddenberry's
son he said some of the episodes he's
yeah he was actually on the bridge he
was like a bridge on one episode and
stuff like that he has come out and said
this is canon basically well you didn't
sit in that way what he said was just as
my dad would have loved these yeah he
would have considered them canon
yeah that's when they're written so well
and they blend in so well with our
old-school Star Trek lore you can
definitely tell these were made with
love these were made by lore masters oh
my god like for instance as the series
starts to wrap up in those two final
episodes you actually hear audio cues
that are actually from Star Trek the
motion picture like you see something in
space that's impressive you're gonna bow
yes like that goes on the more it starts
bleeding you start seeing getting into
the newer CR Trek and they do it just
right that way they're kind of giving
Star Trek a motion-picture some heritage
you know you're the giveth heritage in
the original series which it's awesome
yeah so they you know it was really well
thought out
for instance in the last episode when
the I think was either the Congo or the
enterprise warps away from you
yeah takes off and there's like stripes
stripes behind it and like a rainbow
flash boom and that's from Star Trek a
motion picture yeah that was the way the
enterprise departed you know and yeah oh
well you didn't see that evening the old
original episodes until the final
two-part episode you know the two-part
Alvin alley and on that finale is
awesome because that wraps up some stuff
I cried that you even yeah what's in the
finale is that you get Kirk's five-year
mission debriefing yeah yeah it was
really cool I mean we can say some
things that that kind of tie in too late
to the later series like I said why they
introduced because the cool thing is
that Vicks fiance might be wife now yeah
I think she's still fiance I think last
I heard yeah she plays a ship's
counselor that's right and she's kind of
the prototype for this yeah so like so
that's the whole thing where they're
like she's like an experimental rats
program which explains why there wasn't
one on the original one why there is one
on this one and why there were one on
later yeah later show that when she
appears a court Kirk's dismissive of
that [ __ ] on me that Kirk isn't really
sentimental you know I mean he doesn't
think that he needs that he's he's macho
yeah Oh time you find out that now Kirk
kind of realizes that that's kind of a
good thing to have but you have to you
have you have to see the series I don't
want to say I don't spoil it yeah I'm
just saying that that's something that
kind of paid off later on that I thought
was kind of cool because you know in
case you were watching one of the later
series and were like why did they
suddenly have a ship's counselor where
did that go yeah well they kind of did
they showed where the origin of it was
yeah but another thing I liked about it
is that the female characters in this
series they all kind of have that 1960s
look they're hotties they got the short
skirts and everything but you know there
but none of our bimbos yeah the the
writing for the female characters is
really awesome there there's kind of
strong tough characters but they're
still feminine yeah I mean they're not
they're not you know what's a good way
to put it
they're just like they're like people
not just like eye candy right exactly
you'll see you'll see you'll see yes you
so what was this is gonna be a hard
question but what was your favorite
episode
out of all eleven oh man it's hard to
say they're all really good the mirror
episode well I have like three yeah I
know I don't know if I could pick one
either the one the one where the old
Kirk what was it still trash still trash
the shadow that's actually probably my
which is kind of there's a prison
metaphor going on there and that is also
a callback to an original series right
is that what happens is define that
defiant yeah and there's three there's
two different stories what happened to
the Defiant
Enterprise in the series Enterprise the
Defiant was taken by Tholians right ro
that's right I remember right and then
another version of the enterprise was
thrown into some kind of
interdimensional rift for a while
and when it appears it's got that's what
you'll find out in this episode you'll
see I'm not onto in the mirror episode
is good at the mirror would to call that
fairest of them all Harris to the ball
yeah that's man that's pretty tough yeah
pretty tough to cheat I liked um low
Lonnie also yeah then what about is a
great they're all good you can't really
they really are I mean and they have
kind of even though it's only 11
episodes you get like a good sampling
yeah you know what I mean like there are
some that are set like in Earth's pit
there was one that was set like an
Earth's history yeah you know just like
an original Trek would be one of the
things I like about the very first one
episode one with Apollo Apollo actually
sings in it there's a musical number
yeah
Oh Horace sings yeah that's right that
was like something from the second I'm
the original service yeah so that and
that was the first episode he did so yes
so you could see that that was almost
kind of like his mission statement Rock
he's like I'm continuing continue what
you saw
yeah some stuff from this so we're gonna
have like we're gonna have you saying
just like in the old guys class yeah it
was really really good I was gonna say
oh I forgot to mention that Grant
Imahara of Mythbusters fame yeah he
plays he plays solo and I must admit in
episode 1 sulla has a big scene there
and I kind of think that he wasn't
taking it too seriously just the first
step just that very yeah
and to me I I can see that he was kind
of like you know it's just big Star Trek
but whatever then I think he saw it
afterwards because oh damn no this is
real Star Trek yeah mehran out he was
Sulu yeah I think that he got super
excited and you thought well I'm just
being in a Star Trek fan series right
which like I said you would just blow it
off you think I would Star Trek fans
here yeah
but then when you see it yeah you go oh
he's like oh this is like real stars
real star this is real [ __ ] yeah it is
it is a professional is it totally
professional
it is not amateur in Aspen now you gotta
see you got to see it to believe it and
episode 1 is even though it is a strong
episode it doesn't look as good as
episode 3 and episode 3 doesn't look as
good as episode 8 by the time they start
getting because it's a several years I
mean he made a runners rhyme
they're all good yeah they're all good
but you can you can see that they were
upping their game with each one
with each one because really that
two-part finale was yeah that was
nightlight yeah it hit the two-part
finale is kind of like a mini movie you
know even though it looks like original
Trek it's starting to blend into a
motion picture I don't think it's a mini
movie it's two hours long in it
yeah I think almost two I yes two hours
long yeah because I think the last part
of it was yeah there 48 50 minutes yeah
but and like I said just even though
it's only 11 episodes you really get so
invested in these characters like by the
time you got to the finale like I said I
was like I was crying I think there was
some sad [ __ ] on the Vic wanted to mourn
one of them two more episodes in one of
the episodes that he wanted to do was he
wanted to revisit the gangster planet
from I could have loved that I realized
it action I loved that at which some
people say is the worst Star Trek is
what I really like that one but that
would be a cool to read this maybe you
know what I think it's because I really
liked Leonard Nimoy like a zoot suit you
can I have a thing for Leonard Nimoy
yeah you could revisit that though and
really do that particular episode of
Justice oh yeah what happened after yeah
I mean yeah they're really the play some
games oh that would be really cool
yeah yeah yeah about Spock alright
Leonard Nimoy is almost an impossible
act to follow
yes I would be I would have been freaked
out in something like a not like it was
asked me to it's hard to be Spock you're
gonna be scrutinized the haberkorn does
an excellent job he's really good yeah
he's also stuck in my mind he's also
spot yeah he got it yeah we were
listening to an interview with him last
night too he's mostly no he does like a
lot of voice work he does a lot of anime
voice work yeah he really nailed the
because it's weird how people ask
questions about they ask him because he
plays box they're like oh well is it
harder to play an emotionless character
yeah and that is not an accurate
assessment of Spock he's not emotionless
at all I haven't
he has to keep them under wraps right
which in a way I would think would be
much harder right like a much harder
character play and that's what he said -
and he wraps up the Spock of the
original series really well could you
find out why he leaves start why he
leaves Starfleet yeah like it doesn't
get back to ball one yeah why does he go
back to Vulcan and he doesn't really
leave Starfleet he takes an extended
leave the basses yeah yes yes so that
ties in with the beginning of the Union
picture actually I haven't even seen for
a long time I want to know want to see
that one again
as you know we watched Wrath of Khan not
so long ago yeah which obviously that's
a good one
although I remember liking the most
emotion picture like citing to you but I
did too but I like to wrap them found a
lot better but you know what I mean
there's like I said there's other Star
Trek fan series and actually Vic and I
believe Todd haberkorn have worked on
one of the other ones it's called
Farragut yeah I have to see it and I
haven't seen that what I've heard that
one's very good - okay because like I
said I like the original series but I'm
not I wouldn't consider myself like a
Trekkie I'm not like a total geek about
oh I know all the episodes and stuff
like that I've seen all of the original
series this series is just good it is
just rip this series is just great for
somebody who just happened to have seen
those old episodes on TV yeah have you
seen those own old episodes than you're
doing yourself a disservice you can
watch them for free on Netflix yeah all
of the original series right and they're
quite addictive it's kind of like yeah
watch them overcome yeah very comforting
format you get to learn you get to kind
of become familiar with these characters
and they're kind of comforting in a way
yeah I like that series my favorite
thing I must say about the original
series and one of my favorite things
about Star Trek continues to is I love
the relationship between Spock and bones
yeah yes pretty cool yeah it's a sign of
this [ __ ] kind of you know this [ __ ] I
love that this series has two bones yeah
in the very first episode I think it's
just the first episode I think it's
there's a different guy yeah and he was
he was actually only planned to be a
temporary
from well yeah but he was he's good too
it's like a huge Star Trek he's written
books about Star Trek and all this
others so he's like Star Trek superfan
and his Ben
another Star Trek and then quickly they
introduced the regular yawns and he's a
really good character I like him a lot
yeah he's very he he really captured
that lovable crab eNOS yeah that bone
Stephanie original serie that I liked so
much and I liked him and Spock like
butting heads at the time there are no
dud actors or AB know everyone honest
all of them does the character really
well the first couple in the first
couple episodes the wig that that they
had on O'Hara
I didn't think looked as look very good
on her later on she was wearing a wig
they had a big pony tail yeah that's not
like a her yeah me yeah because it
showed more of her face it was kind of
pulled back and then yeah kind of gave
me that more a vibe yeah but she's
really good also but they real I mean
not and I'm not saying like not even
denigrating the first episodes the first
episode is fantastic yeah right it's
fantastic it was it got better it is
better as it went along like the look of
it got better than acting got better the
writing got better everything got better
yeah so it's just every single one and
like I said that's why it was so hard
for us to pick yeah they're all favorite
they're just really all the writing and
executions excellent on all of them yeah
at 10:00 and I noticed that it got
better as it went along yeah and man
when this series ended I was pissed I
couldn't believe this CBS didn't want
anything - didn't claim possession of
this missile they could have just said
that's ours they don't they wouldn't
have to pay them they would say this is
ours
you're gonna put this on our streaming
service on Vick here man why don't you
do a few episodes in between that motion
picture and rather Kai yeah be awesome I
mean I want to see that series continuum
I really hope it does and for the money
how could they lose I don't understand
how CBS could lose yeah I mean they
really if they want if they want your
science services if they wanted their
streaming service to [ __ ] survive
having more than one Trek at the same
time I think would be a great way to do
it because you can get the new crowd and
the old crowd at the same time because
here's the thing like I don't I I didn't
do the math or anything like that so Vic
funded the first episode entirely by
himself yeah which entailed I mean they
built their own sets they
other and so these sets are spitting
image and think I'm the second value I
am everything is exactly as it's exactly
the same it's either the same or better
yeah yeah so then he did his first
Kickstarter which made about a hundred
twenty-six thousand dollars and that
covered episodes two three and four okay
and then he did a second one and he made
about two hundred and fourteen thousand
and that covered five six and seven and
then he did another one he did an
IndieGoGo and that he almost got two
hundred grand and that was for you know
the other episodes so the fact that he
could make three episodes yeah for that
cheaply yeah and they were that good
no the actors didn't get paid they all
volunteer true all right but still
that's that's a good CBS is willing to I
mean they show that they're willing to
put that much money into a Star Trek
property right so it seems like they
could give them somewhat less because
they don't need as much look at what
Netflix did with MST yeah okay for just
a small amount seriously thank you
forever Netflix yeah that new MST is
awesome dollar-for-dollar you couldn't
make people anymore I have you know and
like I said and and I am super critical
I love the old MST I love Joel I love
Mike I love every single episode I love
every single host segment no matter how
dumb some of all right but and the new
one when the new MSD came out I was kind
of like I was kind of scared to watch it
yeah but holy [ __ ] yeah it exceeded my
expectation look and they're doing a
season two look we've never met Vic you
know maybe one day we'll meet him at a
we do the convention we do horror
conventions instead of sci-fi but maybe
there might be cross for one day I'm
just gonna say neat those suits CBS are
[ __ ] up if you ask me they're [ __ ]
up
that was a winner that would've been a
winner project for them yeah I'm in your
quarters Vic
I mean it might have been a niche
project but still but I really don't
think that's a big thing anymore no
that's not a problem I mean look at how
much in like you said about Netflix look
how much money they're willing to pour
into something that is probably not
gonna be a huge yeah you know that
mainstream America or whatever I was
gonna water my make billions of dollars
right you know like look at what they do
like stranger things are dark that
Germans show that around and there's
also crossover yeah like you get the old
MST fans watching Netflix and you know
but while they're there they're gonna
watch this other series and then they go
to this other so they all kind of
cross-promote I'm not like a super
Trekkie but I'm super into this and I've
watched it like for you can get the old
the the older crowd that likes the
original Trek to get the streaming
service on CBS if that's how they want
to play it yeah okay
so they're white and while they're there
they're watching the new Trek yeah
discovery watching no let's do because
then you could kind of draw in people
that might not have cared about the
exact about discovery there's a new
thing and then the younger people who
are watching discovery say wait what's
this other Star Trek yeah well this is
pretty cool then they go back and
watching the old see why it's the old
one the old CBS private property since
it's a CBS don't know if they're doing
yeah it would seem like a good crossover
site you know maybe they'll wise up and
they'll just piss like I said the first
season what do I get if our listeners
share the free videos on YouTube Oh Star
Trek continues just share that with your
friends we get a whole bunch of people
it's only a matter of time that you know
once you have a few a few million subs
then maybe you know you might do this
then you're gonna get they're gonna get
some attention because you know like I
said how why did Netflix by your MST
because they raised seven million
dollars subscribe to Star Trek continues
on YouTube and share yeah also it's on
Facebook and share but yeah it's a great
show yeah we need to get the we need to
get this one launched
alright so that'll do it for our sort of
quasi movie episode well it's a
recommendation on the series guys go go
eat that one up you're gonna yeah yeah
that's why we didn't spoil too much yeah
yeah your logo if you like the show
remember to Like share subscribe our
show also as well a Star Trek continues
if you'd like to support the show please
remember to check out our patreon at
page
calm / 13 o'clock or go to our vlog at
13 o'clock podcast up WordPress comm and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account if you'd rather give a
one-time donation and remember to stay
tuned for our next episode which comes
out on Tuesday and until next time bye